over the last week or so if there's been
this really awesome tweet going around
that recreates the classic iPod using
Swift UI it contains a click wheel that
you can rotate around to change the
position of the album's in the
scrollable view above it and if you've
ever owned an iPod it will definitely
make you feel some nostalgia as soon as
I saw this tweet I knew that I was going
to have to build it in flutter and
that's what this video is all about if
you're new here like and subscribe and
grab the full source code from fire ship
IO let's start by taking a closer look
at the app we're building in this video
now I realize that everybody is sick of
flutter UI challenges but this video is
really all about the UI we're not going
to request access to the user's music or
play actual audio files but there are
plenty of flutter plugins out there if
your goal is to build a full-blown audio
player now if we look at the top of the
UI you'll see that I have a scrollable
page view widget
it focuses an individual item in the
center and then animates it into the
view when it's moving the off-screen
images are given some perspective so
they look 3d and then rotate it the
rotation is calculated based on their
position in the page view and that's how
we get these cool animations when the
squirrel position changes now moving
down to the click wheel we can go from
one item to the next by clicking the
forward or backwards buttons but the
real challenge with this demo was
creating a click wheel that you can pan
across either clockwise or
counterclockwise and have the scroll
view rotate in the proper direction so
when the wheel is rotating clockwise it
should move the page view to the right
when it's moving counterclockwise it
should move the page view back to the
left and we can do all this with just a
regular gesture detector and some basic
math we don't need a custom painter or
trigonometry or anything crazy like that
in fact we don't need a single
dependency for this project so let's go
ahead and jump into a flutter app the
first thing you'll notice is that I have
a list of image URLs to show the album
covers which is completely optional
because those images sit on top of some
colored containers so you can omit them
all together if you want now down in our
main material app we'll go ahead and add
a scaffold and then inside that scaffold
we'll add our iPod widget the first
thing I'll do is show you how to set up
a scrollable page view in our state pool
widget will first instantiate a page
controller and we'll set the viewport
fraction to 0.6 this allows the next and
previous page to overflow into the view
so you get a preview of what's coming
next which is similar to the classic
iPod UI if you have a viewport fraction
of 1 which is the default it will fill
up the entire view the next thing we'll
do is set up a stateful property called
current page which starts at 0 and the
reason we have this as State on the
widget is because we want to update the
UI anytime the current page changes and
there's multiple ways the user can
change that value either by using the
click wheel by pressing a button or by
using the page view directly we can
update that value whenever a change
occurs by adding a listener to the page
controller so whenever the current page
changes it will trigger a rerender on
the component which will be useful once
we get to the animation part now let's
move down to our build method we'll
start with a safe area widget that will
prevent the page view from interfering
with the status bar at the top and
that's actually an optimization I got
from my friend my woolly Joe on Twitter
so thanks for that from there we'll set
up a column and the first item in that
column will be a container with a height
of 300 and a black background the child
of that container will be a page view
builder the page view builder allows you
to render all of the items in the page
view dynamically it's similar to a
virtual scroll feature on the web where
you're only actually rendering the items
that are visible in the view so it can
handle an infinitely large collection
well pass it our page controller then
set the scroll direction to horizontal
then provide an item Builder function
that contains the current index of the
page in the view now because we can have
an infinite number of pages in the page
view I'll go ahead and create a new
stateless widget called an album card it
takes a color as its input along with
the current index and the current page
now you might be wondering why we need
the current page and the current index
because intuitively you might think that
they are the same value and while
they're almost the same value the
current index is an integer while the
current page is a double as you'll see
in just a second we can compare these
two values to determine how far offset
one of the pages is relative to the
center and we can use that relative
position to create some cool 3d
transformations now let's go ahead and
create the album card stateless widget
we'll start by passing in the properties
that we just talked about and we'll
calculate this card's relative position
from the center by subtracting the
current page from the current index if
the value is negative we know the pages
on the left side if it's
we know it's on the right side from
there we'll set up a container with a
child of a transform widget now I could
probably do a whole video on transforms
so don't worry if this part feels a
little overwhelming our transformation
starts as a 4x4 matrix basically this
allows you to take a 3d point in space
and perform other transformations on it
like translation rotation scale and so
on we produce the actual matrix by
calling set entry and the typical
starting arguments that you'll see here
are 3 2 and point 0 0 1 but feel free to
play around with these to get different
effects from there we'll change the
scale or the size of the widget I had to
play around with these values a little
bit but I found it looked best when I
clamped the values to range between
point 6 and one point out so the page in
the centre will be scaled to 1 but the
pages on the sides will be scaled to
around point 6 and lastly we'll add a
transformation to rotate around the
y-axis based on the relative position
and if you want to get really crazy with
things also go ahead and add a rotation
to the z-axis when it comes to the
alignment of the individual pages we
want the items on the right side to be
aligned center left and then the items
on the left side to be aligned center
right in everything below that is just
your basic UI so we have a container
that has a decoration image with a
network image that points to one of the
images in our list if we fire up our app
at this point we should have a page view
that looks something like this when we
pan across the view it cycles between
the albums and animates the
transformations between them now that
that's taken care of we can move on to
the fun part which is building our
radial click wheel it will take the page
controller that we've already built and
then allow the user to pan
either clockwise or counterclockwise to
control the position of the page view
and we'll also add velocity to it as
well so if the user pans faster it will
scroll through the items faster let's
head back up to the column that contains
our page view builder just below it
we'll go ahead and add a centered widget
that contains a child of a stack the
first thing we'll want in the stack is a
gesture detector and the gesture we care
about is on pan update that event will
fire continuously whenever the user is
moving their finger across this
container for now I'm just going to add
a placeholder function there called pan
handler and we'll implement that in just
a minute
then we can create a circle by setting
up a container
with a width and a height then we'll
give it some box decoration where the
shape is box shaped circle now on the
iPod you have more of a doughnut shape
or a circle within a circle and we only
want to fire the pan event when the user
is moving throughout the outside circle
or the black circle if they pan across
the inner grey circle then nothing
should happen because we're inside of a
stack that's aligned to the center we
can simply add another container that
also has a box shape of circle and
because it has a higher index in the
stack it will sit on top of the
gesturedetector and won't allow the
events to get through when it is panned
over now you'll also notice that we have
different buttons inside the wheel
itself
I'm not going to implement all these
only the forward and back buttons these
buttons also sit inside their own stack
and they're positioned relative to the
circles so they appear in the right
locations the ones that are actually
pressable are set up as an icon button
when they're pressed they'll take the
page controller and then animate to the
current page plus one or if we're going
backwards the current page minus one so
now when the user taps one of these
buttons it will animate to the next page
or the previous page and give us a nice
looking animation in the process and
with that we're ready to move on to the
final challenge and that's making our
click wheel rotatable let's start by
making sure we understand how a wheel
works we can break a wheel up into
different quadrants we have the top
right the bottom right the bottom left
and the top left so those are the
different parts of the wheel but then
the user can actually pan with their
finger in four different directions as
well they can go up down left or right
and if we think of this as an XY axis
then we know that different movements or
positions are mutually exclusive like
the user can't be going X positive and X
negative at the same time or in other
words the user can't move left and right
at the same time now our panhandler
method will have access to the drag
update details for every event and that
event contains things like the delta or
the amount of change since the users
last movement as well as the local
position of that users movement on the
widget itself to make our code readable
I'm going to go ahead and set up
variables for all these different values
since our circle widget has a fixed
width of 300 pixels we'll go ahead and
set up a radius value of 150 we can
determine where the user is dragging by
looking at the local position
the user is on the top half of the
circle if the local position on the
y-axis is less than or equal to the
radius we know they're on the left side
if the local position x-axis is less
than or equal to the radius now we know
if the user is on top then they can't be
on bottom or if they're on the left side
that can't be on the right side so we'll
grab those values by simply grabbing the
opposite other counterpart to determine
the direction of the users movement we
can look at the Delta on the event Delta
is just a fancy word for change it
represents the amount of movement that
the user has made since the last event
in this case we know that they're moving
up if the Y movement is less than or
equal to 0 or they're moving left if the
X movement is less than or equal to 0
and then we can use the bang to get
their opposites just for the sake of
making our code a little more readable
now that we can pinpoint exactly how and
where a user is panning around we'll go
ahead and set up values for the X change
and wide change as their absolute values
and now we need to make this value
negative or positive depending on which
way they're rotating the wheel let's
start by thinking about how vertical
movement should change the rotation of
the wheel if they're on the right side
and panning down or on the left side and
panning up then that white change should
be positive or clockwise otherwise it'll
be negative or counterclockwise so we
just take the total change and multiply
it by a negative 1 now we'll do the same
thing for the horizontal rotation if
we're on top and panning right or on the
bottom and panning left then the change
is clockwise otherwise counter clockwise
so to get the total rotation value all
we have to do is add these two values
together it's also a good idea to add
velocity so if the user is panning
faster it will scroll through the items
faster and we can do that by multiplying
by the Delta distance and now that we
have all the data we need we just need
to use our page controller to jump to a
new position and that new position is
the current page controller offset plus
the scroll offset change that we just
calculated and that's all there is to it
you can now use the same logic to
implement a rotatable knob or some kind
of wheel or any other type of radial UI
widget that the user has control over
I'm gonna go ahead and wrap things up
there if this video helped you please
like and subscribe and consider becoming
a pro member at fire ship IO to get
access to the full flutter' course along
with a bunch of other advanced content
for members only thanks for watching and
we'll talk to you soon
[Music]